for anyone who is confused as to why
power stand hill resigned immediately
after being elected chairman it's
because his mission within the
Association was already complete as by
this time he had embezzled a mighty
subscribe button from a vault and is
secretly plotting to have you press it
to receive regular hunt hunt content
uploaded straight into your YouTube feed
so look he's clever enough to trick you
into doing it anyway so you may as well
get the jump on him and just press the
fun button right now hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and more
specifically welcome to the hunter
hunter Ark review where today we are
winding down from the largest arc in the
series and examining something far more
digestible being the 13th hunter
chairman election on the 13th under
chairman election Ark is the seventh in
the series consisting of 21 manga
chapters and they concise 12 episodes of
the 2011 anime adaptation which is a
much appreciated break from the madness
that was the chimera and talks 133
chapters in 61 episodes and that's
probably where we should begin because
one of the reasons why I love the sock
so much is because it provides a sense
of relief from the events of the chimera
ants because I don't think I'd quite
realize just how intensely invested I
was in such a tiny section of the world
known as ng L Andy Scott oh and it was
magnificent to have everything reopened
to us so all of a sudden I was seeing
characters who almost felt like they
were from a completely different series
like clay Oreo and Hisoka and things
actually began to feel like Han to
Hunter again and the election Hawk does
achieve this wonderful sense of
reintegration in almost every aspect of
its storytelling with much of it taking
place within the hunter Association and
re familiarizing and even expanding
greatly upon its internal structures and
politics which are they enough isn't
something we've really exported that
much since the hunter exam but on top of
that both the main protagonist and
antagonist are members of the Zeltiq
family so we have that nice familiar
connection happening and there are
appearances from all over the last band
of the series many of which can be seen
guarding Paul Paul gone in hospital and
I guess narrative Lee speaking that
really is the core of the election arc
the consequences of the valve that Gong
made briefly to access all of the power
he would ever have to brutally murder in
ephah Pete oh and I do love this idea
because one of the things that puts me
off shown in series the most are grand
actions of sacrifice that don't actually
involve any sacrifice in the grand
scheme of things so gone needing to live
in what Allah me described as a fate
worse than death is a surprisingly
balanced and therefore appreciated
result now with all of that said you
could accuse this arc of doing exactly
what it is I despise which we may as
well get into now with the whole ala
canonical thing because the end result
is that kilowatt was able to use the
Deus Ex
to restore gone to a state of livability
I mean in practice none occurs powers do
have a very balanced function which yes
I do enjoy now over because killer seems
to hold all of the cheat codes he can
rather annoyingly pull off something
that should be impossible and to this
day I'm still not entirely sure how I
feel about it
although I think what tips me in favor
of the decision to find a way to
satisfactorily bring gone back into the
world of the conscious living is not so
much the technical implementation of the
events but moreso how they act as a
reflection of kilauea sheer drive to
protect gone which by this time has
become the emotional meat of the series
so when looking at it through that lens
and not thinking about the aleca stuff
too much I can appreciate this as an
allegory of the power of friendship and
man it sounds so corny when I put it
that way but it really is on to hunter
does friendship right and that's part of
the reason why Killa is my favorite
character in the series he is such a
surprisingly pure existence for a child
assassin that is and this is his arc so
I will always love it for that alone and
while we're here I should also mention
that this is the last we see of the gong
Killer friendship as they part ways in a
startlingly casual manner although on
the inside they are both definitely
feeling it as was I this moment is one
of the saddest in the series because as
far as we know this is it the greatest
friendship in storytelling history comes
to a full stop and a new sentence may
never begin with how the marker is going
but putting that aside and getting into
the salt exit launch as I've already
mentioned we are introduced to another
new family member being a liqueur zoldak
who has by far the most powerful
existence in the entire series residing
within her in the form of nanika I
really enjoyed this for the most part
because nanika is simultaneously creepy
as hell but also like impossibly
adorable especially at the end where
it's feelings got hurt but this is one
of those times where Takashi displays a
supreme ability to conjure something
sinister which is an all-day difficult
thing to pull off properly but everytime
alikum made a request to anybody that
wasn't killer and nanika came out to
grant a wish it was a legitimately kind
of scary moment and for a while hunt
Honda was veering off into the potential
territory of horror and suspense and
that was a very interesting journey
however once again I do wish that the
whole nanika gone business could have
found a bit more of a balanced
resolution which was actually
foreshadowed by Elham II when he stated
that Killa was planning to take the
ramifications onto himself and thus
putting everyone close to him in danger
although in the end there were no
ramifications and that was that I guess
but the Mosel dick family fun let's get
into ellamy the primary antagonist of
the election arc and I have to say first
and foremost that it was fantastic
see another side of this blank faced man
or I suppose any side of him because for
the first time in the series he displays
the powerful sense of desire and
selfishness in wanting to control non
occurs power that instantly transformed
him into an infinitely more fascinating
character for me but what this arc also
did give us is a glimpse of the true
terror of Allah me and what happens when
he uses his abilities in full force to
control armies of people and wreak
incredible chaos which was fun because I
feel like manipulators along with
probably emitters get the most raw deal
when it comes to nen portrayal in the
series all the super cool stuff falls to
conjurer's and specialist transmitters
and even enhancers
but this is a fantastic example of a top
tier manipulator at work using the core
attribute of the discipline but that's
not even it because the zalta crocus
continues into their employees with a
well-deserved return from two favorites
mind being canary and gutter but also
the introduction of Amana and Sue Bonnie
both of whom are quite charming and
captivating in their own respective ways
especially the insanity of savonia who
can use aura to transform into
high-performance vehicles which is fun
but getting back to gato for a second
this is another one of those profoundly
sad moments because as soon as he began
facing off against Hisoka that really
was it and it's so depressing to look
back on because I mentioned in my review
of the Tzadik family arc the gota really
did present more of a classical father
figure tequila and to have got to make
the ultimate sacrifice for his sake only
solidifies that thought in my mind and
in the end the even more heartbreaking
aspect is that the decision is made not
to del kilowatt about quaters death and
instead have a Kirikou impersonate him
into eternity I guess not really quite
sure the grander plan is there but it
was nice to see a minor element of the
hunter exam come back to be quite
relevant and now I guess we should
actually talk about the election portion
of the 13th under chairman election Ark
which is a story playing out in tandem
with Kilowog focusing on finding a
replacement for the former chairman
Isaac Nauta row and elections you know
then on the most exciting of topics to
base an entire arc on especially
fictional ones involving primarily
characters that we've only just met but
with that said I was surprisingly on
board with it pretty much the entire way
the only part of it that didn't quite
have me was right at the beginning where
we were dumped with a load of zodiacs
and spent a ton of time with them just
like making the rules for the election
and it was just a very sudden shift in
tone of ideas from the Chimeran talk and
it took a lot of adjusting to especially
because it took a lot of time to nut out
the personalities of the zodiac
and they didn't really have a lot of
chance to shine whilst they were
discussing purely internal politics and
just on that though I do say dumped with
the zodiacs because we were introduced
to them all at the exact same time which
is a move that I always questioned in
storytelling my personal preference is
to have profound characters like this
drip fed to us throughout the course of
a long-running series like for example
my ever precious one piece one of many
groups in that series is known as the
seven Walid's of the sea and it takes
almost a decade for us to be introduced
to each of those seven members one by
one in different situations which has
the benefit of allowing each of those
characters the time to breathe and
really stake their unique claim on the
series whereas in a situation like this
we aren't bombarded with a legion of
phenomenal character designs but they
all blend into each other and as a
result nobody is allowed to stand out
you know it's kind of weird UI doesn't
know where to look so it just becomes a
big mesh of designing wimey stuff with
that said given the structure of hunter
hunter that was really the way this had
to happen
takashi hadn't really had the
opportunity to drip-feed these guys into
the events of Hunter hunter as we know
it and so I do take it for what it is
although it probably could have been
done better if toga she knew that this
was the point where he wants to get to
while he was still at a much earlier
point in the series
another issue though is that these
characters were almost entirely
overshadowed by the presence of Jing
freaks you know the man who we've spent
this entire series searching for who
just very casually pops up and takes
command here through a mental battle
with Barristan hill another zodiac who
steals the remaining limelight but just
on Jing he's such a a disappointing
character and intentionally so I think
when we finally do see him it's almost
like a bad joke that this lob is what
we've spent the entire series searching
for and you know he's just a classic
deadbeat dad and he even gets called out
for that by the other loveable they Oreo
and even punched right in his face thing
which is probably a favorite moment of
the arc by the way it's just another
classic takashi subversion of
expectations though jing has been built
up as this legendary figure and I'm sure
that in terms of his achievements and
abilities and he probably is but the way
he is portrayed here is anything but
although I do have to say that his
battle of wits against parastone was a
definite highlight of the arc honestly
I'm going to put all of that down to
Paris too though because this man is
quite possibly one of the most
intriguing figures in all of hunter
hunter he has his funky flashy sense of
style and is supremely unpredictable
which as a result makes him an
attention-grabbing figure whenever he is
on screen or page because you never know
when he is going to pull a move like
resigning
chairman of the hunter Association
immediately after winning the election
by default the Sark does have at least
one other star that shines brightly
though which is definitely a Oriole in
my reactions that was well it's about
damn time Lee REO has become very
neglected at this point in the series
and almost forgotten presence of on
tanta nicely by circumstance and that
means that he will never be able to
stand up to our main cast in terms of
any sort of combative ability however he
can prove very useful and effective in
other areas one of which is apparently
getting involved in politics and I
really appreciate that oh gosh she found
a great way to incorporate this much
miss character into the fray during the
sock I was also just quietly hoping for
him to become the next chairman as well
but deep down I knew it could never
happen because he wants to be a doctor
becoming the head of an international
organization would probably hinder that
effort somewhat and now I guess it's
time not to just turn to the end of this
arc but the whole 2011 anime series
because this is it and despite the fact
that the story continues far beyond this
it really is a nice cap to the series
culminating with gone meeting jing atop
the World Tree and for all intents and
purposes fulfilling the goal that he set
himself during episode 1 if Han Tyrande
had ended right here and now I think I
would have been fairly satisfied and as
far as I'm concerned as a primary
protagonist GaN is done he's achieved
what he wanted to and there is very
little reason for him to actually be in
the story anymore and yes you can point
out that he still has threads with
figures like he's so cold gyro but they
really don't mean a lot in the grand
scheme of things because a lot of times
toga she just lays out for shadowing to
intentionally disregard it or change it
later anyway and he himself has even
said that he has ended this series once
being this point and he was highly
tempted to have this be it but the
lustful monger just kept on going and
whatever the case this arc is where we
leave gone and kill Oh which is very
bittersweet and kind of a shame but they
very much had their acts completed in my
eyes and so it's onward with the rest of
the cast
so for 21 chapters the 13th hunter
chairman election arc accomplishes quite
a hell of a lot actually reintroducing
us to the walled capping off two of our
fine protagonists and laying the
groundwork for a fascinating future
including the ever mysterious Dark
Continent which intrigued me so much
that I immediately began reading upon
finishing the 2011 anime and that pretty
much does it for the 13th hunter
chairman election arc but what do you
guys think please leave your thoughts in
the comments below and if you came from
all hunt onto content then please do
check out some of my other videos and
even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt under glory delivered
straight to your YouTube feed
for now this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time